I'll focus on some of the recent data with nivolumab and AVD with the focus on some updates
from the SWOG trial and also looking at how the real-world utilization is shaping up as.
These are my disclosures.
These are the two objectives.
One is to go over three-year follow-up data from the SWOG study and then looking at real-world
outcomes with nivo-AVD and advanced Hodgkin lymphoma.
I think a lot of us are aware of this large cooperative group study that was conducted
throughout the US that compared nivo-AVD to BV-AVD for six cycles in patients who had
stage three and four Hodgkin lymphoma.
GCSF was optional in the nivo-AVD arm, but it was required for the BV-AVD arm, and the
primary endpoint was GCSF.
This study did include patients that range all the way from age 12 to even patients that
are in their 70s and 80s.
So one of the great things about this study was that it was sort of obviously included
patients that were below age 18, 25%, but over 60, about 10% of the patients.
It did include some of the minority patients that we don't see.
And a lot of the clinical trials, including Blacks and Hispanics, and also included some
HIV patients.
So if we look at first, looking at just the adverse event profile, neutropenia was more
common in the nivo-AVD arm, probably because GCSF was not required and was only given in
about 54% of the patients compared to 98% of the patients with BV-AVD.
And as far as the anemia and thrombosis, it was very common.
It was very common to see anemia, thrombosis, and thrombocytopenia, those numbers were quite
similar.
Despite having more neutropenia in the nivo-AVD arm, the febrile neutropenia rate, sepsis,
and infections were less with the nivo-AVD arm compared to BV-AVD arm.
As expected, peripheral neuropathy was higher in the BV-AVD arm, with grade three events
in 8% compared to only 1% with nivo-AVD.
But if you look at immune-related adverse events, which are of specific interest, there
were patients with increased ASD-ALT that were seen, 7% who had grade three ASD-ALT
elevation, and then everything else was pretty much 1% for grade three events, and included
hypothyroid, pneumonitis, gastritis, and some colitis, and very, very few patients.
However, the publication didn't go on.
It didn't go over into specific details on how many total patients had grade three immune-related
adverse events, etc.
So that was one of the limitations.
If you look at the three-year follow-up, the data still holds up, where the three-year
PFS is 91% compared to 82%.
It was 92% versus 83% at two years, so really no major changes a year later.
And then, does not matter what age group you are, doesn't matter what IPS score is, doesn't
matter what the stage is, or whether you have B symptoms or not, nivo-AVD benefited patients
more than BV-AVD.
And most importantly, the outcomes are poor for patients who are elderly in Hodgkin lymphoma,
classically, but with this study, what we see is that the two-year PFS in age greater
than BV-AVD is improved by 25% compared to BV-AVD.
Additionally, there's improvement in overall survival for these patients.
This is likely because more patients in the nivo-AVD arm were able to finish all six cycles
without any dose reduction, so 69% versus 26%.
The rate of discontinuation was quite low, 14% versus 55%, and non-relaxed mortality
was 10% less with nivo-AVD.
So this really accounts for...
Why this regimen is so well-tolerated in this patient population.
Now, so we went over the clinical trial data.
Some of the questions that are not answered by a clinical trial is, you know, obviously,
how does this data hold up in patients who are not on clinical trials?
They tend to be a little bit more sicker, they probably have more autoimmune diseases,
etc.
Also, adverse events.
They're usually more.
And then what happens to these patients after they progress?
So this study, which was just recently published by Dr. Bach, who is one of my colleagues at
the University of Utah, included 327 patients across the whole U.S. that have been treated
with nivo-AVD for advanced Hodgkin lymphoma.
So this did include a lot of minority patients, so Hispanics, African-Americans, almost made
up 30% of the population.
This also included about 8% of the patients who had a history of an autoimmune condition.
So this is obviously something that was not present in the SWOG study that we know of.
So if you look at the adverse events first in this patient population, we do see a lot
of nausea.
And we do tend to see this more commonly in the younger patient with this nivo-AVD regimen,
nausea affecting them more than elderly patients.
So we do see a lot of nausea in the older patients, and we do also see a lot of nausea
in the older patients.
in the younger patients.
So we do see a lot of nausea in the older patients, and we do also see a lot of nausea
in the older patients.
So we do see a lot of nausea in the older patients.
So we do see a lot of nausea in the older patients, and we do also see a lot of nausea
about 9% of the patients. They were in distribution similar to what was described
in the SWOG study with hepatotoxicity being most common, followed by inflammatory arthritis,
colitis, and adrenal insufficiency in about 1% of the patients. These are all grade three events.
And if you look at any events, obviously there were pneumonitis and inflammatory arthritis that
were also very common in this patient population. If you look at specifically in patients who had
autoimmune conditions to start with, which is on the left, those patients, when they were
challenged with NEVO-AVD, they did have more immune-related adverse events than other patients
as expected. And as you can see, pretty much everyone had their inflammatory condition got
worse, basically.
While getting treatment with NEVO. And some had more than one immune-related adverse event.
So this just gives us a little bit of data in terms of treating these patients with more
precaution, especially if they're requiring a lot of systemic autoimmune therapy.
PFS curve, one-year PFS was 95%. So pretty similar to what we would see, but obviously
longer follow-up is required. And oral survival looks pretty good.
And then lastly, this is some of the data that we're waiting to see in larger number of patients.
About 17 patients progressed. And of them, six of them received BV plus chemo during salvage.
Seven of them received immunotherapy plus chemo. And then two of them received BV-based treatment.
And I think this is informational, but hopefully we'll get some more data with,
larger number of patients in terms of what's done for patients who progress after NEVO-AVD,
because the data is currently lacking.
So in conclusion, with the SWOG study, obviously, NEVO-AVD is currently the standard of care
in the United States. Obviously not everywhere in the country, not everywhere else in the world.
Especially very well-tolerated at an age greater than 60, improves PFS by 10%.
And if you look at the real-world utilization, the outcomes in terms of PFS are similar.
But there is more infection seen, probably similar incidence of immune-related adverse events.
But one thing to notice is that there are more immune-related adverse events seen in patients who have active autoimmune disease.
So this is something that needs to be monitored pretty closely.
That's it. Thank you.